State and territory governments have also been inviting
health workers and teachers for the skilled
nominated visa
Subclass 1, 90.
I believe that state and territory governments
and department of Home Affairs
need to collaborate closely
so that they can avoid
duplicating invitations across similar occupations,
particularly
when the same individuals receive invites
for both the 1,
89 and the 1, 90 visas.
If the department of Home Affairs
can collaborate with the state centeretries
to ensure that the same applicants
and same professions are not being invited,
then this could mean that
applicants in other occupations
will also stand a chance to get invited.
This financially,
this approach
will mean that other professionals can also contribute
their skills to Australia's workforce.